set your proton packs get ready to melt
some marshmallows and buy your copy of
people's sexiest man alive because sony
has brought this franchise back from the
dead after 2016's reboot i mean four
female ghostbusters the feminists are
taking over i'm an adult virgin
ghostbusters afterlife is pure nostalgic
cranked up to 11 and in this video we'll
be going over its connection to previous
ghostbusters movies its ending and yes
those post-credits scenes which hint at
a potential sequel but before we start
busting you know what feels good make
sure to like and subscribe so i can
finally move out of my parents basement
ghostbusters afterlife begins
overlooking the shendor mine in the
fictitious town of summerville oklahoma
which was actually shot in alberta
canada evo shandor was the primary
villain in the ghostbusters video game
and also designed these central park
apartments which served as the
resurrection location for the ancient
sumerian god gozer we'll get into her in
a bit part of the mystery of afterlife's
opening centers around egon spangler who
after the events of the first two movies
has abandoned his family and friends to
live alone on this secluded farm a
secluded farm which his daughter and
grandkids inherit after his death at the
beginning of the film it's this event
that kickstarts the movie's plot cali
spengler egon's daughter along with her
kids phoebe and trevor moved to
somerville after being evicted they
really have nowhere else to go and
callie's relationship with her father
was well non-existent she even remarks
how there's not even one picture of her
in the entire house but over the course
of the film will begin to unravel the
mystery of egon's past and why he chose
to shelter himself from the rest of the
world including his family and things
start to get even more mysterious when
phoebe uncovers a hidden floorboard in
her grandfather's home a floorboard
which contains a ghost trap also known
as a muon trap what she doesn't yet know
is that the trap contains a demon that
could bring about the end of the world a
demon her grandfather sacrificed his
life to contain so naturally she takes
the trap to school to be examined by her
teacher gary gruberson yes that's his
real name they along with phoebe's
friend podcast attempt to open the trap
not knowing it contains one of the two
demons needed to awaken gozer now here's
where it gets a bit complicated if you
haven't seen the original films gozer is
the main villain but in order to awaken
her you need her two minions the key
master and the gatekeeper which take the
form of these weird-looking dogs who can
also inhabit the bodies of humans only
when these two entities are together and
placed on a conduit like the top of the
central park apartments in ghostbusters
1 or the chandra mine and afterlaff can
gozer be summoned if one of these
minions were to be trapped or killed
gozer can't resurrect so when phoebe and
gary unknowingly release this minion
that was trapped by egon they've set in
motion a sequence of events which lead
to the end of the world but not to worry
egon has planned for this within the
mind lays a giant hole which contains
gozer and her demonic army every once in
a while the demons attempt to escape
causing these unexplained earthquakes
around somerville but egon had set up
multiple particle throwers those guns
the ghostbusters use to keep the demons
at bay should they attempt to escape and
this seems to have worked for some time
that is until the key master in demon
dog form takes control of paul rudd's
character and he destroys the particle
throwers allowing hundreds of demons to
terrorize the earth for those of you who
have seen the movie you'll also have
noticed two interesting things about the
shandor mine one are the sequence of
numbers surrounding the ruins which
depict major events the kids refer to
this as a prophecy for example here are
a list of huge events that it predicted
in the year 1883 it predicted the
krakatoa eruption in 1908 the tunguska
event which saw a meteor explode in
siberia flattening over 80 million trees
but more importantly there is 1984 which
were the events of the original
ghostbusters and now there's 2021.
something happens this year that could
cause terrible destruction but even
creepier than these prophetic numbers is
the corpse of evo shandor himself
something about his body being next to
this demonic hole has preserved it and
every time the hole erupts it brings him
to life for a few seconds and it's only
when the demons eventually do get
released that evo is resurrected back to
life fun fact evo is played by jk
simmons who has appeared in every one of
jason reitman's movies this is a really
minor role since a few minutes into his
resurrection he's ironically killed by
gozer the entity he so desperately tried
to resurrect while this is all going on
cali uncovers her father's secret lab
remember how i said he never had any
pictures of her well he's got an entire
wall of pictures articles and
achievements down here that he's been
keeping track of her whole life and it
becomes apparent to her that yes her
father did abandon her but it was so he
could protect humanity from this
impending demonic invasion and not only
that he's rigged his entire home to be
one giant ghost trap and this giant
ghost trap is where the final act takes
us phoebe lures goes her to the farm in
an attempt to trap her but gozer gains
the upper hand and just as it looks like
humanity is doomed the original
ghostbusters arrive all dressed up in
their uniforms ready to bust some ghosts
earlier in the film phoebe called former
ghostbuster raymond stance asking for
his help but he didn't seem too keen on
helping in one of egon's crackpot
schemes especially since he abandoned
the other ghostbusters just like he did
his family but when he finds out this is
egon's granddaughter and the fate of the
world is at stake that might have
changed his decision but even the three
ghostbusters aren't strong enough to
take down gozer and only when phoebe
joins in with her gun with the help of
the ghost of egon that they're able to
spring the trap and contain gozer for
good now the ghost of egon doesn't have
any lines and that's because the actor
who played him harold ramis died back in
2014 but there are some really emotional
scenes where callie gets to finally hug
her father even if he's just a ghost
before the credits rule there's a nice
four herald dedication that plays now
the film does boast a mid and end credit
sequence the mid credits are mainly fan
service which sees bill murray's dr
peter venkman and sigourney weaver's
dana barrett recreate the esp shock test
from the original film it's never
explicitly stated whether the two are
married but they can be seen wearing
wedding bands it also takes place in a
home perhaps theirs and no sign of oscar
dana's son who is just a baby in
ghostbusters 2. in the films we never
find out who his father is then there
are the much juicier end credit scenes
which sees winston zedmore talking to
former ghostbusters secretary janine
malnets janine makes an appearance
earlier in the film showing cali the
farmstead and it's implied yet never
explicitly stated that she is cali's
mother this could be true considering
janine had eyes for egon in the first
film afterlife even shows a deleted
scene from the 1984 movie which sees
janine give egon a lucky coin if you
play the scene even further and
apologies for the quality here this is
what dr venkman has to say about their
relationship janine
didn't your mama ever tell you not to
get involved with no ghostbusters not go
on home as we continue we see winston
has turned into quite the businessman
amassing a large fortune with his
company he's even been paying the rent
for rey's bookshop this fortune looks
like it'll come in handy as winston can
be seen visiting the rundown
ghostbusters fire hall with someone
driving in the ecto-1 car so it looks as
though winston has bought the property
and is ready to bring the ghostbusters
back and this would probably be a new
generation of ghostbusters as this film
seems to be passing the baton the final
shot however is a bit more ominous the
camera focuses on the containment device
one that we've seen in the original
movie flashing red this is accompanied
by some fairly nefarious music
suggesting something's in there that
wants out so if they are setting us up
for a potential sequel it looks like it
will revolve around getting the
ghostbusters back up and running no word
yet if a sequel has been greenlit but i
want to know what you thought of
ghostbusters afterlife was the franchise
brought back from the dead or dead on
arrival i want to hear your thoughts in
the comments below thank you for
watching everyone be sure to like and
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
always follow me on twitter and
instagram at thingstoryt until next time
remember
daddy loves you very much
you